Centennial programs with biographer
Michael Reynolds this book Hemingway the
final years was published this month its
mr. Reynolds fifth and final book in a
series looking at the life of American
writer Ernest Hemingway mr. Reynolds
talked about mr. Hemingway and his book
recently in Oak Park Illinois or mr.
Hemingway spent part of his childhood
the event takes place in the high school
Hemingway attended as a boy this brings
us to the official business of our first
session this morning and so it is a
great pleasure to introduce Mike
Reynolds had a chance to work as closely
with Mike as I've ever worked on the
panel yesterday that I referred to and
watched him handle the kinds of
silliness and the kinds of well intended
I think often but misleading comments we
hear about Hemingway in a manner that
was truly noble and intelligent
reflecting the 2527 years he's put into
Hemingway scholarship in doing five
volumes of Hemingway biography several
other books on Hemingway a threat to do
more revision on Hemingway in the future
Mike is professor emeritus from North
Carolina State
he's the newly elected president of the
Hemingway Society
he's agreed to squeeze us into a several
week series of engagements dealing with
a centennial he's done the website in
New York Times an introduction to
Hemingway I encourage you to read very
nice overview and has been a longtime
friend of the foundation
he was our invited speaker in the early
90s for the birthday and it gives me
great pleasure to introduce Mike
Reynolds
[Applause]
good place to be at this time of year
this time of the century I see a lot of
old friends out there I'm particularly
honored i CHR Samba back there who's
never gotten up for a lap for anything
this early at a conference it is my
pleasure to to speak to lecture the
choir as it were on Hemingway as an
American icon this is not my first trip
dog park as you might imagine I've been
coming here since the seventies off and
on and but this is kind of a culmination
American iconography is an amazing
collection of disparate events and
people from our collective past
Washington Crossing the Delaware
MacArthur coming ashore in the
Philippines names faces that we admire
respect detest fear most importantly
names and faces we recognize Ben
Franklin self-made man Babe Ruth
watching the ball go over the fence Joe
McCarthy demagogue Marines raising the
flag at Iwo Jima their images that are
remembered and tell us something about
our own collective psychic needs because
we remember them to achieve widespread
recognition in one's own time of course
is crucial to becoming an American icon
but the status does not come
automatically just because you're
important while you're alive isn't
enough to reach that higher level of
recognition one must endure in the
nation's consciousness Abe Lincoln
became such an icon Honest Abe the
uncommon common round we put his face on
the copper penny where the poorest of
the poor can see it every day we put his
General Ulysses Grant on the $50 bill
I doubt if you put ulysses s grant
picture on the front of Life magazine
today that anybody would recognize him
although $50 bills are becoming more
prevalent aren't they
some like Charles Lindbergh achieved
status through one daring Act one
perfectly performed moment others
achieve it through notoriety Al Capone
we remember and recognize Statesman
military men athletes entertainers but
few and far between are the American
writers whose faces remain in the public
domain long after their deaths
if Henry James were to walk in today you
would more of you would probably
recognize him than the general audience
but I'll tell you it would be a picking
him out of a lineup might be tough from
our literary pantheon only a few have
reached the status of icon Whitman Boat
Wayne and Hemingway come to mind each of
him crystallized something new in
American letters Whitman is the
fountainhead of American poetry like it
or not Poe of American Horror Train of
American humor and Hemingway I would say
is the fountainhead of the modern voice
of these four only
Hemingway's face carries multiple and
often contradictory connotations as I'm
sure most of you are aware born a
hundred years ago
Hemingway imprinted himself deeply into
the literature culture and social psyche
of an America that was changing from an
upstart nation into a world power that
generation of the 1890s Fitzgerald
Faulkner Dos Passos and Hemingway
changed forever
how Americans wrote about themselves and
how others saw us these writers and
their contemporaries became the
modernists of the 20s and among them
Nome was more prominent than Ernest
Hemingway seventy years after the last
roar of the 1920s I mean ways face still
requires no
fine caption he's as well recognized in
Shanghai as they using Grand Forks in
his frenetic public life and private
life Hemingway had the uncanny ability
to be on the edge of whatever important
was about to happen after being blown up
in 1918 in Italy he took us in his
fiction and his journalism to the fore
wars that followed for a nation of
increasingly City bound spectators
Hemingway's life became a media event he
took us into Africa with dangerous game
out on the Gulf Stream for Marlin he was
a living example of America's promise a
young boy from Oak Park who set out to
be the best writer of his time with
plucked and locked talent and wit hard
work and hard living he did just that in
the process he told us that pursuit was
happiness that Duty mattered and that
any story followed far enough would end
badly before he burned out he remodeled
the american short-story changed the way
characters talked confronted the moral
strictures confining the American writer
and left behind a shelf of books telling
us how we were in the first half of this
century his friends scott Fitzgerald one
sudden how difficult it was to believe
in the youth of one's parents you might
say the same of the youth of Ernest
Hemingway who grew so mediate all that
it's hard to thank you for him here in
Oak Park as a high school freshman
finishing last in the cross country Ron
finished glassed the next year in the
cross-country run is to is a matter of
fact but he finished that's important
it's hard to think of him as a young man
in Paris magnetic brash body a writer on
the edge of immortality later speaking
of himself he said it's always a mistake
to know an author well there were those
who agreed with him remembering him in
his flaws others no matter how badly he
hurt them never ceased to defending this
literary pushing and shoving which began
early didn't thrive until he was dead
and famous among his survivors for some
he was the most important event of their
lives poor Harold Loeb for example who
tried all of his life to stop being gone
in The Sun Also Rises and on his
obituary page in The New York Times
there it was once again for some he was
the most important event for others he
was only a summer storm crossing the bay
but no matter how he touched them not
the least of his conovan taters ever
forgot the look and feel of him never
forgot the way his Archibald MacLeish
son but he sucked the oxygen out of the
room simply by walking in the door women
those who loved him and those who did
not remember him in great detail one
woman said I wouldn't have been
surprised that anything Ernest did he
was unexpected in a temperamental a
lovable person who took a great deal of
understanding he was sensitive although
he didn't seem to be if you didn't know
him well you'd think he was rather tough
his first wife remembered him as one of
the most sensitive people I ever heard
of and easily hurt she also said well he
had the nerve of a brass monkey I don't
think it was nerves she was talking
about exactly but she said he was the
kind of man whom men women and dogs were
attracted to he was scornful of some
people would say outrageous things about
them he had a cruel streak it is
kindness went just about as far in the
other direction
Keva canal who was became part of the
Sun Also Rises thought he was phony
pretentious untrustworthy but she never
forgot his Apple cheeks his infectious
grin nor his boyish and boyish
enthusiasms men who were drawn to him
had difficulty performing at his level
of intensity
for Hemingway did nothing half-heartedly
many enjoyed the bullfights few of them
followed them all summer as he did I
enjoy fishing I wouldn't mind doing the
little deep-sea fishing two or three
days I don't think I could go out sixty
days in a row
Ernest did whether it was skiing fishing
drinking he was competitive Mike Strider
said he always had to win gerald murphy
found the writer Hemingway huge in
forceful he are diverse stated
everything talked so rapidly and so
graphically and so well but she found
yourself agreeing with him all of these
men were older than Hemingway he was the
youngest one in the bunch whether it was
the at the corrida in Pamplona the ski
slopes and Sean's or an evening at a
Paris dancehall the Hemingway experience
always demanded unexpected emotional
resources few of his male friendships in
those days lasted longer than five years
reading their letters in those earth you
can watch them burn up and out like
incandescent lamps to whatever he
touched he added scale and a sense of
importance Murphy said the lives of some
of us will seem I suppose by comparison
peddling for me he has the violence and
excess of genius he may not have
outlived his friends and enemies who got
in their last words but he burned so
much more brightly than most but we
still read their statements by his light
we know so well the icon he became it's
difficult to imagine him unfledged
vibrant with energy laughing joking
along the boulevards of Paris wearing
sneakers old trousers a patched jacket
his long hair sticking out from
underneath cap six feet tall
broad-shouldered moustached and handsome
setting his own style friends said you'd
see him walking down the Montparnasse
people would wave at him from the cafe
he didn't quite recognize him then he
would see them and his grin would be
infectious and he would smile and soon
everyone was smiling
by moving with a curious slow footed
gait he was a man on his way somewhere
else always today his name in face as
you well know appear in strange and
diverse places more than a few problem
drinkers salute Ernest as a kind of
patron saint without ever having read
his fiction at mahogany bars in Key West
Bimini Havana Madrid Paris and countless
other places you can still find a face
here and there claimed to have shared a
drink with Hemingway
the night that he told him such-and-such
and I'm if I had had a drink with
everybody who's told me he's had a drink
with Hemingway I probably wouldn't be
here today at the Floridita there is the
infamous or famous Papa Doble occurring
at the Ritz Hotel there's a Hemingway
bar which wouldn't let me in because I
didn't have a tie on wouldn't let Paul
Smith on either hardly a metropolitan
area is without its moveable feast
restaurant paramilitaries you'll be
happy you know of various stripes use
Hemingway quotes as personal sign-ups on
their email big game hunters Marlin
fisherman
boxing enthusiasts in hardcore
journalists think of Hemingway as one of
us Democrats and staunch Republicans
find elements that in Hemingway that's
the point their point of view in 1992 I
was in Moscow where they knew our man
from Oak Park as well as I did the
previous year a 600,000 volume edition
of For Whom the Bell Tolls had been
reprinted in paperback and it sold out
when one year in Russia the old USSR
there's been a Hemingway conference in
the heart of China and there's a
Hemingway society in Japan which is
thriving
he's been translated into the let my
last count was about 20 or 22 different
languages
what other American author has six
houses preserved in four different
states in one four
country has a street name for him in
Pamplona a line of Sporting Goods in New
York a look-alike contest in Key West a
fishing contest in Havana an annual pin
literary award a bad writing contest in
Venice and now a line of furniture can
you imagine a William Faulkner
look-alike contest
if you ask there's people who tell you
he's been dead for 38 years but when we
look around there's artists seemingly
alive and will on the face of a stamp or
in a Mercedes at our publishing another
new novel
unfortunately the image that we have
most deeply embedded in some ways is the
old Hemingway that karsh portrait and
the Keywest look-alike contest honors
the old man not the Hemingway of the
1930s when he lived in that peaceful
outpost I suggested to him that they
they should have a 1930s Hemingway
look-alike contest they weren't
interested in that
he didn't begin as the old Hemingway any
more than I began is the 62 year old
becoming decrepit Rennels nor was his
rise to fame instantaneous in 21 when he
arrived in Paris he was unpublished
unknown barring introductions from
Sherwood Anderson to people like Ezra
Pound Sylvia beech Gertrude Stein
through Sylvia he met James Joyce
through pound he met Ford Madox Ford he
worked on the transatlantic review I'll
tell you four I want to be writer with
those kind of introductions if he hadn't
turned out to be Ernest Hemingway we
would have been disappointed he
connected with every expatriate American
writer in Paris through Gertrude Stein
Salani fell in love with Susan's
paintings and met young artists on the
rise andris Kwang Ramon Miro Picasa he
met Joyce at Sylvia Beach's lending
library by 1924 there were rumors on the
on the street that the handsome young
man from Oak Park was thought by
insiders to be a writer of some promise
little and obscure magazines were
beginning to publish some of his poetry
which I won't quote for you this morning
because we're being typed for c-span
that was being read by the smarts up in
the East Village
before ever meeting hemming one scott
Fitzgerald wrote max Perkins at scribner
sign telling him about a young man named
Ernest Hemingway misspelled of course
because Fitzgerald misspelled
Hemingway's name almost to the very end
a young man named Ernest Hemingway who
lives in Paris and has a brilliant
future over the next two years Hemingway
proved that true with two books in our
time classic now a classic collection of
short stories it was being stories that
were being taught in the classroom by
the time Hemingway was 32 and of course
his Roman à clef of the fair mean son
for a mean Faria the Sun Also Rises
leaving his mentor's
Anderson Stein pound behind and with his
College equivalent education completed
Hemingway was quitting Paris just as the
first impression of him as expatriate
was forming he said I was never an
expatriate I was living in Paris because
it was cheap to live in Paris that's
what most of us were doing lost
generation we were never lost beat up
maybe but never lost Hemingway in the
30s asked Scribner 'he's to stop putting
out biographical information about him
he wanted his private life to remain
private but it was already too late when
he divorced his first wife the story
appeared in The New York Times
photographs caricatures line drawings
wood cuts were appearing in national
magazines young handsome virile talented
he was a contradiction the active man
who excelled at the contemplative life
book reviewers spoke of his writing in
phrases uncommon in the previous age in
fact I'm gonna quote to you from the New
York Times review of in our time and it
sounds like they're describing an
athlete Hemingway has a lean pleasing
tough resilience his language is fibrous
and athletic colloquial and fresh hard
and clean
inlene spare sentences he always makes
you see the thing he writes about it
sounds like they're talking about
Michael Jordan doesn't it I mean they
didn't have a way of even describing the
way he was writing 1930 bestseller fair
world arms out was making his name more
commonplace he moved to Key West Florida
just as the Great Depression was
rearranging the face of America a more
remote location would have been
difficult to find as would a less
expensive one Key West was half-empty
down on its luck on the verge of
bankruptcy ideal base of operations for
a writer many of you have been to the
Key West house that house was purchased
in the 30s for $8,000 not a bad
investment between 30 and 36 he was in
and out of Key West creating a different
writer from the writer of the 20s in
case you hadn't noticed
Hemingway's writing changes dramatically
in the 30s on purpose choosing not to
repeat himself while poet Arian writers
their names now largely forgotten we're
writing about textile mill strikes
Hemingway gave us death in the afternoon
and natural history of the Spanish
bullfight as well as the statement about
the responsibilities in life of the
artist when Key West allowed the federal
government to take over the management
of that devastated fishing port it went
bankrupt about 1934 Hemingway published
green hills of Africa a safari book and
a book of athletics a writer's book
going against the grain of the leftist
literary 30s Hemingway was ever his own
man never another face in the crowd his
novels were being translated into French
in German a movie of The Farewell to
Arms came out starring Gary Cooper
Hemingway's writing was being regularly
imitated in parodied in prominent places
death in the rumble seat appeared in The
New Yorker with the statement with the
usual apologies to earn his teeming way
who must be pretty sick of this sort of
thing
while depression-era movies gave us
escapist films where the gentlemen wore
tuxedos have you noticed on the lawn
late night television anytime it's in
black and white film and the guys are in
tuxedos it's from the 1930s in the
middle of the Depression I've never
quite understood that but while that was
happening Hemingway was writing a series
of personal essays called letters for
the newly founded men's magazine Esquire
subject matter was always himself
himself in Africa on the Gulfstream in
Paris
Spain Cuba Key West wherever his
interest took him and took us with him
in formal essays which were frequently
inter larded with informal photographs
of Hemingway the author in action at sea
on the Serengeti
brawny bearded in a clean shaven America
bare chested he was who he was and
America loved him for it
single-handedly he became a spectator
sport for increasingly sudden Barre
Americans when he voted a huge black
marlin the photograph was in Time
magazine when he returned from Safari
the New York Times was at the dockside
waiting for him
wherever he went whatever he did fish
hunt brawl travel marry or write the
media was close at hand
his Esquire voice was personal
frequently humorous combative prophetic
in September of 35 he warned his
audience about the next war he said it
would begin within two years two years
later he was in Madrid reporting on the
Spanish Civil War and that October he
was on the cover of Time magazine in his
at last experimental work from the 1930s
to have and have-not was published
without a public relations team without
a literary agent Hemingway in the 1930s
had gained the public recognition
usually reserved for movie stars and
national politicians his thirties ended
with a play on Broadway the fifth column
and his incredible bestseller for Whom
the Bell Tolls half
million copies sold back when half the
million copies was a big sale I mean
guess Stephen King wouldn't think so but
Life magazine documented the novel with
pictures in the Spanish Civil War when
he met with Ingrid Bergman to discuss
possibly being in the movie Life
magazine again was there over the next
10 years
Hemingway published no fiction at all
yep Saturday review of literature in
1944 polled its readers Hemingway was
the leading American novelist by
two-to-one
his name was being dropped regularly in
syndicated columns of Edmund Wilson
Leonard Lyons between June and December
of 44 Hemingway covered the European war
with manic energy deliberately putting
himself into dangerous situations d-day
June 6 1944 most correspondents observed
d-day from the correspondents ship which
was offshore safe out of range and
watching it through glasses Hemingway
went aboard her landing craft to get a
closer view his head was still ringing
from a severe concussion as he rode the
LCI into the fox green sector of Omaha
Beach if you've seen Prague Saving
Private Ryan you have seen the movie
version of Fox green sector that's what
he was filming a thousand men died on
Omaha Beach that day the landing craft
that Hemingway was rotting in took
machine-gun fire avoided mines but it's
infantrymen ashore they turned to the
mothership safely that bloody morning 10
other such crafts were blown out of the
water
Hemingway's luck held as he said and he
described it in voyage to victory part
of what he had seen I saw a ragged shell
hole through the steel plates forward of
her pilot house where an 88 millimeter
German shell it punched through blood
was dripping from the shiny edges of the
hole into the sea with each roll of the
LCI
her rails and Hull had been be fouled by
seasick seemed seasick men and her dead
were laid forward of her pilot house at
the end of that month he twice flew
missions with the RAF intercepting
German v1 rockets coming into England
this is the pilots memory of one of
those evenings and I'm quoting him he
earnest seemed to love the fireworks
bursting all around us and urged me to
press on I was acting against my better
judgment if you did blow one up
particularly at night it was
touch-and-go for yourself that's this is
a British pilot am I gonna do British
but touch-and-go we dived even more
steeply on the second v1 gave it two
long bursts I pulled away in a confusion
of searchlights an intensive flock as we
winged over there was a huge flash
behind us in the airplane danced around
like a leaf in a world wind Ernest
seemed to have loved every minute of it
in July he was back in France on the
ground attaching himself to the 22nd
division where his own activities became
news and I'm reading you little
headlines out of the New York Times
Hemingway is injured Hemingway captures
six a close Hemingway call Hemingway's
son captured Hemingway still at the
front
Hemingway's son is liberated I don't
know of any other journalists in World
War two that got headlines like that
under the guise of journalists he became
involved with David Bruce whom he had
known in Cuba at the Embassy and got
involved with the OSS a matter of fact
Hemingway actually applied for a job
with the OSS to use his journalists
credentials as cover the OSS decided
they this was back in May of 44 that
they probably couldn't use him because
they weren't sure how he would behave
under orders which is
probably just as well but with David
Bruce and the OSS and working with
French Resistance he organized the
defense at Brown Ballet gathered
intelligence for the push into Paris on
August the 25th the feast day of st.
Louis Hemingway was leading a small
group of French and irregular is in
regular gi's into the liberation of
Paris and eventually to the Ritz Hotel
he was in and out of Paris that fall
alternating between the battlefields and
the Ritz when he wasn't sick with colds
and sore throats you're suffering from
recurring headaches from an aggravated
concussion Hemingway was by turns brave
gentle obsessive foolhardy loving brutal
a man surfing along the edge of his
manic drive that fall with the German
army retreating behind the Siegfried
line Hemingway spent three days in
Hurtgen vald with the 22nd Infantry of
the men who went into hurt convolve with
the 22nd 85% were killed wounded missing
in action tremendous losses there
Hemingway was in the middle of it an
active participant in it taking the same
risks and came out of it unscratched
somehow later he said I was reborn it
hurt convolve between 45 and 61 whatever
private life he had was long gone he was
constantly being sought out by reporters
columnist war buddies baseball players
and a new to breed of academics who were
teaching and publishing his fiction and
also by colleagues sophomores four of
Princeton sophomores showed up at his
front door uninvited rather than turn
him away he invited them in mixed
martinis and talked to them for a couple
of hours then wrote a letter to Carlos
Baker
same stop sending your students over
here
when his fourth wife Mary suffered a nun
most fatal tubular pregnancy in her
other remote Casper Wyoming the story
was in the New York Times the next
morning her fallopian tube burst she was
hemorrhaging to death Casper's not a big
town the surgeon was off fishing he
didn't get back into that evening they'd
almost run out of blood for plasma to
transfuse on the operating table Mary's
veins collapsed her pulse stopped the
surgeon told Ernest kiss her goodbye
tell her goodbye because I can't operate
if I operate now the shocks gonna kill
her
Ernest turn to the intern and said who
had Ernest had seen enough battlefield
wounds and blood plasma to know what was
happening
he's in the operating room cut for the
vein he said cut for the vein found it
got the needle in the blood wouldn't
flow the plasma wouldn't flow
he started milking the the plasma line
got the plasma flowing into or she
fluttered back to life they performed
the operation and quite literally he
saved her life he may have been a son of
a [ __ ] but I'll tell you in an
emergency you would like to have Ernest
Hemingway right there beside you when he
hunted duck sir went on vacation Time
magazine reported it January 49 million
zuv Life magazine readers read Malcolm
Kali's portrait of mr. papa
with all the pictures between 14 41 and
61 Life magazine published 16 feature
stories on Hemingway more than any
literary agent could possibly have
arranged well the time by this time
Hemingway was larger than life legend
during his exploits real and all the end
otherwise were widely known and it was
hard to tell which were true in which
were not 1950 Lillian Ross's profile in
The New Yorker famous or infamous was
published EB White did a parody across
the street and into the grill
and in the 50s the biographers were at
the front door and Hemingway was fending
them off like a good general giving up
ground slowly and protecting his flanks
critics announced with the publication
of across the river and into the trees
that Hemingway was over there this was
the end of Hemingway as a writer of
fiction and as an important figure in
American literature two years later he
wrote the old man in the sea and there
was a lot of Crow being eaten around the
u.s. the old man in the sea was
published in Life magazine five million
copies of Life magazine sold out in one
week his work was being translated into
all the major languages of the world in
54 the two plane crashes in Africa
produced headlines Hemingway's dead
obituaries appeared friends and enemies
begin giving quotes to newspaper men
that they wished afterward they hadn't
given in some cases and of course then
they found him alive and then the plane
crashed again and there was the
concussion and Hemingway coming out at
Antibes trying to say you know my luck
she still holds it's okay
I'm not really hurt he was badly hurt he
was concussed II had head injuries he
had back injuries but the reporter said
he came out of the jungle carrying a
bunch of bananas and a bottle of gin
Ogden Nash wrote a song called
Hemingway's and it starts out with a
bunch of bananas and a bottle of gin not
well remembered Ogden Nash but there you
have it he fulfilled
later that year 54 he was canonized with
the Nobel Prize time and again during
the post-war period his books and
stories were turned into Hollywood films
some of them not so memorable you
remember to haves and have-nots you know
how to whistle don't you just [ __ ] her
up and blow that famous Hemingway line
often suspect you know William Faulkner
worked on that film script and often
wondered you know if it was sabotage but
then hey my paranoia knows no limits the
by the time of his suicide his it was a
two-week running story in most major
newspapers of the world but by that time
we had used him up from the grave
however he has published five books and
this year 38 years after his death we
finally have true at first light a quick
count of my bookshelf before I left
Santa Fe I counted 18 full or partial
biographies of Hemingway either the man
or the writer or both his houses are
preserved here and in Oak Park that now
the pfeiffer house in Picador consol is
preserved it's going to be a Hemingway
Writing Center Key West Ketchum Cuba
each summer its Sun for me
thousands of admirers drink themselves
silly on in Pamplona and follow Camino
Heming the way to the bullring to
achieve and maintain this level of
public recognition is more rare than
winning the Nobel Prize more elusive
than great fortune and perfectly in
keeping with him anyways mantra which I
won't give you in French but translates
roughly first one must endure this year
of his centennial there will be
pilgrimages here to a park
other Hemingway sites the faithful armed
with guidebooks Hemingway's Paris
Hemingway's Key West
Hemingway's of Arc there'll be more
stories more television documentaries
celebrations deprecations Jonathan
Yardley I'm sure will have something
good to tell us I'm sorry I should have
said that you could cut out when you get
at this thing all of which get me in
trouble all of which will reinforce his
name and face as an American icon to
become an icon is a mixed blessing for
the revenues public quickly sucks the
real man dry no matter how are you
he seemed in the media Hemingway aged
quickly and the image that he in part
created was a difficult one to face and
fate with failing health yet his life
story was horatio alger writ large
unknown young man with a high school
education who made himself into one of
the most admired and imitated writers of
his century one of the most recognized
men of his century he became whom he
wanted to be and we the American public
made him into an icon a representative
of a writing style or a lifestyle that
we admired in the desired attested and
knew we would never have he was the
designated hitter for his generation he
took the risks we could not afford play
the game for which we locked the skills
sustained the hearts that we avoided and
wrote the stories that moved us despite
Wars injuries mental and physical
illness in his strenuous life Hemingway
left permanently embedded in our
literary history several of the finest
short stories written in this century or
any other time at least three possibly
four major novels and a writer's life
carried out on an epic scale we read his
works in the same way a surveyor reads
geodetic benchmarks it doesn't matter
whether you like the elevation or not or
admire the view at least you know
exactly where you are his clean
well-lighted style has at some point
influenced most american writers of this
century that he self-destructed affirmed
his humanity that he wrote as well as he
did promises his permanence whether one
admires him any way or not he is an
authentic artifact a piece of the
continent an American author whose
career changed the face of our fiction
those who know little of his life and
less of his writing call him macho a
word he never used those more
knowledgeable appreciate the complexity
of the man his message was simple and
true
we are doomed to lose so we must lose on
our own terms
that is all that has left us we exiles
from the Garden of Eden thank you
Michael Reynolds was the associate dean
and professor at North Carolina
University he now lives and works in
Santa Fe New Mexico mr. Reynolds is the
author of a five book series tracing the
life of Ernest Hemingway this is the
last in that series Hemingway the final
years was published this month by WW
Norton & Company the book is reviewed in
last Thursday's New York Times